دخان المعارك في السودان يخفي ازمه
انسانيه تتسع مع مرور الايام على الحدود
مع تشاد يعبر كل يوم الاف سودانيين
الفارين من المعارك يحدث الامر ذاته على
حدود السودان مع دول اخرى منها مصر
واثيوبيا وجنوب السودان هؤلاء السودانيون
يتوجهون من الخرطوم الى وادي حلفا باتجاه
المعبر الحدودي مع مصر من الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
كانت اثنين مليار وما في الولوج عشان احنا
نطفه بالمبلغ ده ولم ين كل الاشياء عندنا
دولار عندنا ذهب وركبنا لحد ما وصلنا
طلعنا من الجوف التوتر والضرب لحد ما
حصلنا حالته تتدفق على هذا المعبر بين
السودان ومصر عائلات سودانيه كثيره قادمه
من العاصمه الخرطوم ومن مناطق اخرى حسب
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره هاجر نحو 100 الف
شخص الى دول الجوار منذ اندلاع المواجهات
في الخامس عشر من ابريل يعقد هذا الوضع
عملا المنظمات الدوليه التي تعاني من نقص
حاد في التمويل تقول الامم المتحده ان
منظماتها الانسانيه والمنظمات الدوليه
المتعاونه معها تعاني من عز في التمويل
بلغ مليارا وخمسمائه مليون دولار وان
الاستجابه للنداء المشترك من اجل السودان
لسنه 2023 لم تتعدى 14%
هذا النقص في تمويل ينذر بكارثه انسانيه
اذا صعد الطرفان المعارك وخرج الوضع عن
السيطره فالامم المتحده تتوقع الان فرار
800 الف شخص الى دول الجوار والرقم يمكن
ان يرتفع حسب التطورات العسكريه في
الميدان مع العلم ان اغلب دول الجوار
تعاني من مشاكل داخليه ولن تقوى على تحمل
عبء هجره بهذه المقاييس هذه نياله عاصمه
اقليم جنوب دارفور تدفق على المدينه الاف
النازحين الفارين من المعارك في المناطق
المجاوره حسب المنظمه الدولي للهجره اجبرت
المعارك اكثر من
30000 شخص على النزوح داخل البلاد لا يبدو
السودان وجواره قادرين على تحمل عبء ازمه
انسانيه كبيره فسنوات طويله من الحروب
والاضطرابات السياسيه والجفاف انهكت
الجميع